[Music]
my name is Dave Smith I'm a developer
advocate here at Google working on IOT
platforms and today I'd like to spend a
little bit of time talking to you about
how you can build cloud services for
smart devices and how you can integrate
those services with the Google assistant
we're gonna walk through some components
of an example cloud service solution and
then we'll discuss a little bit of how
you can connect a service like that to
the assistant for smart home device
interactions all right so let's get
started so voice assistants have
accelerated adoption of smart devices in
the home they've become the common
thread that enables different
manufacturers to work seamlessly
together inside of one space now the
smart home API enables developers to
integrate their cloud connected devices
with the Google assistant and leverage
the natural language processing that's
built into the assistant for processing
queries and commands for those devices
that are in the home smart home is part
of actions on Google which is the wider
platform designed to enable
conversational engagements with users
through assistant enabled devices
however smart home uses a more
simplified model of interaction that
abstract away some of the conversational
pieces of a typical to voice action just
out of curiosity how many of you have
developed using the actions on Google
platform before okay so for those of you
who have you're familiar with some of
the conversational interactions that
typically take place when building an
action and using smart home you're gonna
see that some of that is simplified
quite a bit developers don't really have
to interact with the request and
response model of talking to the user we
focus more on the devices so with smart
home integrations we focused on creating
a clear and structured interface for
devices devices are broken into device
types and traits which provide a well
understood schema for reporting those
device capabilities to Google you can
see an example of two of those device
types here on the slide in the light
device and a thermostat device and we
have many others as well
within these individual device types
these encapsulate a series of what we
call traits that define what the
capabilities are of that device so for
example with the light that device can
be turned on and off you can adjust the
brightness or you can in some cases
maybe modify the color setting whereas
for a thermostat you have the capability
of modifying what we call the
temperature setting okay and then within
each individual trait these are further
subdivided to provide individual
attributes that describe the state of
that particular device so for example
with the thermostat the temperature
setting trait defines three attributes
for that thermostats mode like heat or
cool or off or auto things like that the
temperature setpoint as well as the
ambient temperature okay so we we put
all these things together to define what
we call the device schema to provide
known device types interactions with the
Google assistant now having such a well
defined schema enables the assistant to
bring highly intelligent interactions
about how they process queries and
commands because it now has a strong
understanding of what those devices are
and what those devices can do in other
words with smart home we we allow Google
to handle the conversation so that the
developers can focus on the devices the
Google assistant also adds contextual
understanding to your devices through
the home graph home graph is our
technology that understands the
relationships between structures rooms
users and devices home graph is what
powers our ability to understand user
queries in context of the environment
and be able to translate that back to
individual devices it enables us to say
things like turn on the upstairs lights
or what's the temperature in here by
providing that relative context between
the user and the devices around them all
right quick show of hands how many of
you in here own a assistant enabled
device in your home whether that's a
smart speaker like a Google home or a
smart display like Home Hub that I have
up here okay good good good now for
those of you who raised your hands how
many of you have at least one smart
device
in your home that is connected to that
assistant device okay good good so about
half maybe a little bit less so what I'd
like to do here is I want to quickly
show you a demo so that everybody is on
the same page of what this actually
looks like in practice so up here I have
a Google home hub and I have a nest
thermostat and I'm just gonna walk
through some very simple interactions of
how we can interact as a user with the
assistant with one of these smart
devices so let's quickly switch to the
demo the mics back on
alright so wake up my devices here
alright so well as a user I've installed
both of these devices in my home and I
can I use the Google assistant to set
these devices up add them to rooms in my
home and do all these pieces associated
with the home graph that I just
described and what that enables me to do
as a user is walk up to my device and
say simple queries like hey Google
what's the temperature on stage it's
currently 71 degrees so this is the
smart home API in action right basically
what's happening is Google is connecting
to the partners cloud service in this
case nest and it's asking for the
current state of that particular device
and then reporting that back to the user
notice also that I'm referring to that
device by its location in this case on
stage and this is because the assistant
has assigned that device to the room
using the home graph when I initially
set it up now because the home graph
knows that this display and that
thermostat are both in the same room I
can also make more relative queries like
hey Google what's the temperature in
here it's currently 71 degrees we get
the same result right similarly we can
send commands to these devices to make a
change hey Google set the temperature to
65 degrees okay setting the stage to 65
degrees and we can see the adjustment
also made on the thermostat as well so
this is again using that smart home API
but in this case Google is sending a
command to that partner cloud
integration to say you need to adjust
the state of this particular device and
in this case is providing a new set
point okay now even here we can make we
can use Google's natural language
understanding to make more natural
queries at the same time hey Google make
it a little warmer you got it
warming up the stage okay now the other
nice thing about integrating your
devices with the Google assistant is not
only do you get this voice interaction
but on assistant surfaces that have you
I like this smart display or an Android
phone or an iOS device you can also
interact using the touch UI so for
example you saw it for just a moment but
I'll bring it back up quickly I can look
at the view of that device on this
display and I can interact with it
directly to make that change on the
device as well okay now all of this
functionality is built into the Google
home app into Google assistant devices
and all you have to provide is the
interaction of how to ask your devices
for information and how to manipulate
them through commands and we're gonna
talk a little bit more about how all
that stuff works so let's switch back to
the slides the mics off all right so
there's two things that I want to go
over with you here today and the first
that we want to discuss is let's talk a
little bit about how do we actually
build a cloud service that communicates
with devices so quickly just kind of
showing you a diagram this is
essentially what you just saw in the
demo right the user can interact with
this an assistant enabled device and
that assistant device will interact with
your cloud service in order to
communicate with that particular device
so the smart home interaction is a cloud
to cloud integration okay which means as
a device manufacturer you have to
provide your own cloud service for users
to register and manage their devices and
then the smart home actions platform can
integrate with that cloud service using
a series of web hooks to control and
access those devices we'll talk more
about that in a little bit
now depending on where you are in your
development process you may already have
this functionality in place for your
devices but I want to explore a little
bit of what an example might look like
if you were to build this device cloud
service on Google cloud so this is an
example architecture using services from
the Google cloud platform as well as
from firebase that we use to fulfill the
requirements for the smart home use case
now the sample code for what I'm gonna
show you is on github so I recommend
that you take a look at that after the
talk it's an end-to-end sample that
includes the cloud service as well as
client applications for mobile and web
interactions with sample devices all
that stuff so in this sample
architecture we have cloud IOT core
which enables secure device connectivity
over MQTT or HTTP we're also using
firebase which enables easy client
application development for mobile and
web through their series of native SDKs
we also get access to firebase
authentication
which adds the ability to provide user
identity and access control over all of
this data now in this example devices
report their current state through IOT
core which then bridges that data into
pub/sub and through to cloud fire store
using firebase authentication and fire
store we can build client applications
that expose that data directly to users
for device management and then users now
have the ability to control their
devices and they do that by updating the
data in fire store which then triggers
commands back to the devices through IOT
core now this means that in this
architecture fire store becomes the
primary source of truth for all of your
device data and that's going to become
really important when we start talking
more about smart homes so I'll come back
to that a little bit later on but just
keep in mind for now that cloud fire
store is that central point where all of
the data is accessible for all of the
devices okay so why cloud IOT core IOT
core enables secure connections to
Google cloud for resource constrained
devices okay think
all tiny $1.00 microcontroller less than
a dollar type devices right generally
speaking if you're building something
like a smart light you're not gonna want
to put a quad-core processor in there
running embedded Linux
I hope instead you typically want
low-power devices that have very low
footprint and all of those things so we
use cloud IOT core to enable those
devices to connect directly to Google
cloud and that's done two ways the first
is using MQTT which is a low overhead
protocol that is design is ideally
suited for IOT devices or low bandwidth
devices okay we do also support HTTP but
generally speaking most users of IOT
core are using the mqtt protocol
primarily for this reason the other and
probably more important reason is for
authentication so we need to make sure
that these devices have a secure
connection to Google cloud and as I
mentioned before generally speaking we
try to get the smallest lowest footprint
cheapest device we can into these smart
home devices whatever we need to to
supply the use case this often
introduces constraints on both the CPU
as well as memory primarily memory right
the cheaper the device the less onboard
memory it's gonna have in addition to
this IOT solutions really to be secure
need a mutual authentication solution
okay it's not enough for the device to
be able to trust the server that it's
connecting to it's just as important for
the server to be able to trust the
devices that are connecting to it in an
IOT situation okay so we need have
mutual authentication going between
these two pieces
generally speaking you would solve that
problem with something like a mutual TLS
stack on your device or on your client
however typical mutual TLS stacks
require way too much memory for a
microcontroller in a lot of cases
whether it's the stack itself or the
fact that the client is also responsible
for housing the full certificate chain
that it has to supply up to the server
all of that stuff can blow out the
memory of a microcontroller very very
quickly so cloud IOT core is designed to
solve this problem by creating an
asymmetric authentication between
the two it still uses TLS 1.2 to
authenticate the server to the devices
so IOT core still presents certificates
it can be validated on the device and
all that stuff but the devices
authenticate themselves back to coyote
core using a much simpler public/private
key authentication making mechanism
using JSON web tokens or jots okay
basically what happens here is when an
IOT core device is connecting to the
service it signs a jot with a private
key that is stored privately and
securely on that device and then
provides that jot as the password for
the connection to IOT core over MQTT or
HTTP the public key is shared at
provisioning time with IOT core so it
can use that public key to validate that
the information coming in from this
device is valid it is the device ID that
it's claiming to be and all of those
things so we still have a secure
authentication mechanism from the client
device back up to the server but it's
using a much more lightweight process
that is more easy to fit into these
constrained embedded devices than a
full-blown mutual TLS all right one of
the advantages of using firebase
authentication for user identity and
access control is security rules does
anyone develop using firebase in here
okay just a few people firebase is an
amazing platform it is built on Google
cloud but it adds a bunch of additional
developer services that make it really
really integrated seamless and easy to
use and one of those is firebase
authentication integration with
datastore using the security rules so
with security rules we can seamlessly
integrate user permissions to access the
firestore data using a very simple
declarative rule syntax without having
to write any code right and this syntax
allows us to validate based on the
authenticated users and the information
that we have about them what types of
data in the database should they be able
to access right and this is a basically
a snapshot of the firestore rules from
the intent example that we have which
allow us to control that only
authenticated users should be able to
access device data and they should only
be able to access the devices where we
have marked them as the owner of that
okay now the logistics of how all that
happens is you can look in the sample
code but the basic idea is with just a
couple lines in the rules we apply that
over our entire database okay so it's
very simple it's very seamless it's easy
to do we can also restrict not only user
access but users ability to do things
like create new devices right so that we
can mediate the process of device
registration and we'll talk about that a
little bit more in a minute okay
along with fire along with security
rules one of the other primary
advantages of firebase is the ability to
build client apps as I mentioned before
so this is a screen shot of the mobile
app that comes along with the end-to-end
example this happens to have been
written in flutter using the native
flutter SDK that's available for
firebase firebase also has SDKs for
Android and iOS and on the web we have
SDKs for react angular and many many
more right so it's a very easy system to
integrate for front-end applications
both on the web and on mobile okay and
this enables you to very quickly create
properly functional applications to
enable users to authenticate access
their devices manage them control all of
those types of things now the mobile
application in particular is actually
quite important because it's part of a
critical path for device provisioning it
allows users to activate and register
their devices so I won't ask for a show
of hands this time but I'll bet that
those of you who mentioned that you have
activated a smart device in your home
before more than likely you had to
download the mobile app from that
manufacturer to provision that device
whether it was on your network or with
your account or any of that this is a
very common pattern because it's a
device that we can pretty much assume
that all users will have with them right
some devices can do this on the web most
of them use the mobile app so let's dive
a bit deeper into the device
provisioning process and how we might do
this with something like cloud IOT core
so within IOT core I mentioned before
that devices use this public private key
authentication mechanism when they
connect to the service so one of the
things that's the OEM where the factory
is responsible for doing is producing
that key pair and ensuring that the
public key is shared with IOT core and
the private key is securely store
on that device before it's boxed up and
and ready to ship that basically creates
the initial device association to say
that this is a valid device this is its
ID or serial number or whatever you want
to provide that can be done by the
manufacturer but then at some point
later when the user actually takes this
thing out of the box we have to have a
way for them to prove that the device
they have in front of them that they're
trying to register is a valid device
that we know about okay one of the ways
that you can do that is you can share
that same public key with the user so
that they can provide that public key
during device registration and allow us
on the backend to validate that the
public key matches the one that's in IOT
core for that particular device ID okay
there's a number of ways you could do
that in terms of how that information is
shared one example which is how we do it
in the in the example code that I
mentioned to you earlier is you can bind
that public key to something physical on
the device like a QR code and this is a
very common provisioning method that's
used by a lot of smart home vendors one
of the nice features of this
functionality is that it actually
enhances the security of the device as
well overdoing provisioning methods
wirelessly like ble or mdns or some of
those others not that there's anything
wrong with those but they require
additional layers of security to make
sure you can prove that that device is
the one you're talking to right when you
physically bind this data to the device
you can guarantee that the user has to
have physical access to the device in
order to register it okay so you can
bind all of that data maybe you want
some additional metadata like the device
serial number or anything else but the
public key in this example is the one
that's most important you can encode all
of that onto the device using something
like a QR code and then because all of
our mobile devices have cameras you can
use the mobile application to scan that
QR code gather that information easily
not asking the user to type it in or
anything like that I just scan the QR
code submit that device information up
to firestore and then our back-end
service can then validate that
information so the user basically
submits a request to register this
device with a particular device ID and
public key and then in the backend we
can validate with
IOT core oh yes that device ID does
exist here's its public key and that
actually matches what the user has just
given you okay so we know to a
reasonable degree of certainty that the
user actually has the device in front of
them if they're trying to register okay
and then from there we can create the
actual device node assign that user ID
as the owner and then the user can see
it in their mobile app on the web okay
so that's kind of a quick overview of
the example code I encourage you to take
a look at the code we also have a couple
of blog posts out on that that are
linked from the repository as well to
kind of give you some more detail on the
nitty-gritty of how all that was put
together so let's shift gears a little
bit now and talk a little bit more about
now that we have a cloud service built
what does it mean to actually integrate
that service with the Google assistant
how do we get the interactions that I
just showed you before with a smart
display or a smart speaker or devices
like that so this diagram kind of
outlines the basics of how the Google
assistant expects to interact with your
cloud service when you're integrating
the smart home API integrating with
smart home basically requires you as a
developer to implement the pieces appear
that are in yellow which boils down to
two primary elements the first is
account linking which is represented by
that web sign in flow that you see up
there at the top and the second is
intent fulfillment which you see between
the cloud services there in the system
so we're gonna talk about both of these
in a little bit more detail here
starting with account linking so account
linking is a process that initiated from
within the Google home app that enables
users to authorize access to those
devices so some of you have probably
experienced this before but just kind of
talk through the idea if a user wants to
enable their smart home device through
the assistant they go through the Google
home app they decide they want to add a
new device and they click that they want
to link their existing account from some
other vendor like nest or whoever to the
Google assistant that triggers a sign-in
flow through this account linking that
enables them to log in as that part
using the account that they had with
that partner device and then authorize
that the Google assistant can have
access to all of the devices that are
man
by that particular account what you're
seeing here is just a screenshot of the
account linking implementation that we
have provided and again in that
end-to-end example that's on github so
smart home account linking really boils
down to three primary elements now for
those of you who are familiar with OAuth
2.0 this is going to look very familiar
because basically what we require of
your service is to be able to expose to
us an OAuth 2.0 compatible endpoints so
that we can do an authorization code
flow with your cloud service okay so
that that basically means we need to be
able to handle the authorization step
which is the user signing in and
granting access and then later on in the
process providing access credentials and
refresh credentials which again is a
typical auth flow for those things
they're real so in the example if you
were to go and look through the example
code on github we've implemented this in
the following way
so the authorization step we interact
with firebase authentication which is
really nice because it means we don't
have to have write much code to do this
firebase authentication handles this
part of the authorization flow very well
the user can sign in using the same
account and then we can use that users
ID token provided to us by firebase as
the authorization code that we can
provide back to Google okay
very little code involved in this part
then later Google will pass that
authorization code back to our cloud
service asking us for what's known as a
refresh token this is basically a
persistent token that should be valid as
long as the users account is linked to
the assistant okay so this is something
that we on our side need to generate
return and then we persist it in
firestore now in the example if you look
through the source code which you'll see
is that we actually used the same jot
standard to create the tokens for this
purpose that IR to IOT core uses to
authenticate devices this is the same
standard in case you're looking at the
code once we've created this refresh
token we can then return that back this
is a token that now authorizes Google to
periodically request access credentials
from
our service known as access tokens so
this Refresh token will
be passed back to your service during
after the account linking process
periodically to get what's known as an
access token access tokens are
short-lived they expire at some time in
the future which is why this process
happens periodically so that when that
token expires you can give Google a new
one and so on and so forth okay
so similarly when we get this Refresh
token it's our responsibility to
validate that the token we received
matches the one we persisted for this
particular user if it's not it's an
invalid token and then if we if that
does match then we can provide an access
token and then later on that will be
used in future requests for intent
fulfillment that we'll talk about in a
minute for accessing actual device data
okay the last piece to account linking
is at some point the user may decide to
unlink their account from the assistant
when that happens you'll receive a
disconnect message and your cloud
service basically in our example just
needs to destroy the token that we
considered valid as a refresh okay there
are a number of different ways to
implement this and in a lot of cases you
can even use even use third-party
services that support OAuth like
all-zero or maybe you've already got
this in your application but this kind
of gives you an idea of how we built it
in the example code in case you want to
see what this might look like
implementing it for yourself alright
let's move a little bit now to intent
fulfillment so smart home intents enable
users to access and control the devices
that they've linked through voice
interaction as well as through the
Google home you I remember I kind of
showed you both of those as we were
going through the demo smart home
intents the fulfillment basically
requires that you handle three primary
intents a sync intent a query intent and
an execute intent so the sync intent is
basically provides information to the
assistant about what devices this user
control the query intent allows you to
return the current state of a particular
device and the execute intent is what
you'll use to modify the state of a
particular device okay so let's look at
these in a little bit more detail maybe
there we go so the sync intent is sent
automatically after account linking is
complete
so this is the assistance attempt to ask
your cloud service what are all the
devices that this authenticated user
controls and what can those devices do
okay so your job is basically to respond
to this intent by providing the metadata
about all of the device types and the
device traits associated with the
devices under that users account right
so in this example the user might or we
might return a response that says this
user has four light devices in their
account all four of them can report the
on-off trait but only two of them
support brightness right something along
those lines so this is a kind of
metadata that you provide in response to
a sync now generally speaking syncs are
not performed on a regular basis by
default a sync is only performed when
the account is linked okay and this this
can be problematic if this is the only
thing that your service implements
because it means that if the user adds a
new device they have to actually unlink
their count and relink it again to see
the new device okay now we mitigate this
by enabling you to call a method through
the home graph API called request sync
so if inside of your application users
add new devices or remove devices or
maybe just the devices that are there
change capabilities in some way you can
use the home graph API to tell the
assistant to request a new sync
something has changed we need you to
send a sync again and when that happens
you'll get the same sync intent so that
you can respond with the new set of data
the new set of devices and capabilities
associated with that particular user
okay so request sync is very important
because it enables it enables users to
have a seamless experience between the
Google assistant and your application
and not forcing them to manually rethink
or relink their account or anything like
that just because they bought a new
device right and applied it to an
existing account all right so the query
intent query is responsible for
reporting the current state of an
individual device or a set of devices in
this case the assistant is asking you
from some more specific information
about what is this device current
is the light currently on is the
thermostat set to 20 degrees or 25
degrees right so in this case your
response is going to provide back the
actual values for all of the device
traits and attributes that you provided
that this device was able to report
inside of the sync this includes whether
or not the device is online or offline
if you're tracking that kind of status
okay
the query intent is typically triggered
when the user navigates to a particular
device from the Google home app or maybe
through voice when they say something
like what is the temperature in here
right as soon as that request is
triggered then the this intent is going
to be sent to your cloud service and you
need to send that back with the result
okay
now both the sync intent and the query
intent in the end-to-end example that
we've been discussing both of those only
have to go so far as firebase right
because in the architecture that we've
created firestore is the source of truth
for all of this data so I can get all
the information I need about what
devices a user owns what they can do and
what the current state of those devices
is simply by talking to firebase I don't
have to actually go all the way and do a
round-trip to the devices which is very
important because it enables those
queries coming back from voice to be
instantaneous right you're not seeing
this long latency while we actually
block waiting for something to go all
the way down to the device and back okay
so this enables a much quicker
interaction with the Google assistant
the execute intent enables you to modify
the state of your particular devices
based on a user command so this
basically comes in and describes a set
of traits that should be updated for a
given device or a given set of devices
and these can be provided in a group so
you can get an execute intent that says
you should modify on/off and brightness
for these three lights okay and then you
do all of that in a single set that
basically is what allows us to be able
to make some of those more complex
queries like turn on the lights upstairs
there could be six lights from three
different vendors in that particular
group and this enables us to make sure
that that all happens in
will command okay the response from an
execute intent is a little bit different
because we're not actually telling the
assistant any more information about the
devices we just need to tell the
assistant whether that succeeded or not
so you can tell it for any particular
one of those devices did the command
succeed and succeed really means that
you know it got down to the device the
device made that change and reported
that it was successful back to you okay
so this is a case where you might
actually be talking to cloud IOT core
directly depending on your application
okay in the sample we don't actually do
that we modify the state of these
devices through fire store and because
of that the responses back from the
device that a change has actually
happened is asynchronous so in our
example we actually return a different
state than success which is pending
pending tells the assistant that yes
that a command is expected to succeed
but we haven't seen it yet okay you can
also tell the assistant if you know for
some reason that that command failed
because of an error or maybe because the
device isn't reachable because it's not
online okay so all that information can
be reported back as a result of an
execute intent for each individual
device and then as you might expect this
is the type of intent that your cloud
service will see when the user walks up
to this device and says something like
set the temperature to 52 degrees all
right that's going to be packaged up as
an execute intent and then sent down to
your cloud service okay now one
additional piece of information here
that's relatively important to implement
it's not required per se but provides a
much better experience similar to
request sync is there's another API call
through the home graph that we call
report state if the device changes state
locally for some reason maybe it's a
light switch and they actually walked
over and flipped on the switch I know
it's weird to think of but it actually
does happen or maybe they change that
state outside of the assistant right
maybe the in your client application or
through the web they modified the state
of that device this is something where
that state change isn't known
automatically by the Google assistant
and by default this is not a huge
problem because whenever the user wants
to ask something you'll generally
initiate a query any
way but queries have latency to them so
what you can do to improve this
experience is implementing the report
state API where anytime one of those
local state changes happens that you're
aware of you can report that state
change to the assistant by providing the
exact traits and values that change for
any given device this can drastically
reduce the number of query intents that
your service sees because if there are
recent state changes on a device Google
assistant can actually look those up
locally without having to ask you again
okay in addition in cases where like in
our example that I mentioned before
where state changes in response to
commands might be asynchronous so you
can't actually tell in response to an
execute whether the command succeeded
and so you return pending instead
reports state is the way that you can
basically tell the assistant ok that
command has actually changed okay
because it happened in an asynchronous
way you can call this API this is the
new state of the device okay so report
state is really helpful for confirming
those successive pending commands and in
reducing the latency between those
potential queries by notifying the
assistant of those changes as they
happen ok that's pretty much it so just
to quickly summarize we talked about
cloud IOT core as a way to securely
connect constrained devices to Google
Cloud we added firebase as a way to
easily build those authenticated client
apps to give users access to those
devices and then we included the Google
assistant as a way to provide
intelligent interactions with those
smart home devices
[Music]